i'll start with my speech
as chair of the children and family law
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
on the general report website the notice
for this meeting
note that meeting notice complies with
house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 603-271-3600
or email hcs.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer is the staff
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
madam clerk would you call the role for
attendance please
thank you madam chair representative ali
stay
home with dog representative all
schiller
representative belanger oh good morning
sorry representative alessia it didn't
unmute in time
this is representative altschuler and
i am home here in my office in stratham
thank you hello
representative belanger uh i am
present in the lob and i would like to
thank you for pronouncing my name
correctly
thank you representative thank you
representative cross
vice chair representative grossman i'm
sorry
simone i apologize no apologies needed
i am here in the lobby
room 308 with
other legislators
representative grossman
i am home i'm here alone
thank you
representative
i am here i am in my spare room alone
thank you
representative luigi i'm here with the
lob with the other legislators
representative litchfield yes i am here
i am
in my vehicle and i do have two children
with me
are you safe and pulled over i
am safe and pulled over yes sorry we
just finished a dental appointment so
we're gonna
hang out for the hearings all right
thank you
thank you represent representative long
i'm here at my house alone
thank you representative petrino
i'm here in my home office alone
madam chair representative rice
good morning i am ending i'll be with my
colleagues thank you
representative smith i'm here home
with my husband and two of my three kids
representative was here
good morning i am home with my baby
representative
morning i am home with my girlfriend
thank you madam chair so everyone is
present
except for representative gross cross
is that yes okay great thank you very
much
and thank you for toughing this out with
us i know you're not feeling well
thank you okay so i'm going to open the
public hearing
on sb 16.
and i will call on
one second
um grant bossie he's
not he's on there
you're just raising money very very
nope i'm trying christina we're having a
hard time pulling
mr bossy in there we go
there he is
thank you mr bossy can you there you are
good morning good morning madam chair
members of the committee thank you very
much for having me my name is grant
bosse i am the
majority policy director for the new
hampshire senate and i am here today on
behalf of senator sharon carson who is
the prime sponsor
of senate bill 16. um as
uh the prime sponsor of many bills she
is actually introducing
another one of her primes uh in another
committee at this very moment
and has asked me to pinch hit i
appreciate your courtesy
this bill revises the formula for the
term alimony
to bring new hampshire in line with
recent changes in the federal income tax
code
specifically the bill recognizes that
alimony is no longer
either deductible by the payer or
taxable
to the payee some of you may be familiar
with this bill as it was
uh debated last year as senate bill 444
that bill was rolled into one of the
omnibus bills that was
vetoed so we're back at it um
i would defer on any of the tax
questions to the tax experts that are on
uh and ask for the committee's uh
careful consideration for
senate bill 16. thank you very much
great thank you very much next we will
have
marilyn mahoney
who has asked for five minutes to speak
in support
of the bill
hello um my name is marilyn mahoney can
you hear me
yes okay great um i
am speaking on behalf of a group of
attorneys who
uh we called ourselves the alimony
working group
um we had met and and developed the
original
alimony formula for the law that is
currently in effect
and that bill coincidentally went into
effect at the same time that the tax law
changed the taxable nature of alimony
which through our formula that we had so
carefully developed into
chaos well not chaos but disarray
because
suddenly payors who were expecting to
have
a deduction
for their payment of alimony weren't
going to get that deduction
and and uh it was completely
uh unfair for that
those percentages to continue as they
were so
the alimony working group reconvened
and we ran a number of different
scenarios to try
to determine what percentage
would be would result in similar
outcomes for both the recipient and the
payor of alimony so that the tax
consequences would not have a negative
or unfairly positive
effect on either party
after a number of meanings and running a
number of different scenarios
um we were we came to the determination
that
uh the 23 of the difference in gross
incomes
produced similar results to the 30
that was in the original law
so that is the primary thing that this
bill is designed to do it also provides
a window for people with alimony orders
that were effective
on or after january 2019 that is under
the
30 percent to modify
their any any alimony orders that were
made
using that percentage on the basis of
the
change in the tax law that window would
be open
for any orders uh amounting to more than
23 percent of the difference and
uh we we didn't want that to be an
open-ended um
a window for anyone to come in and
modify
so we you will see in the bill that the
request for modification must be made by
july 1st
2022 which we felt was a
fair enough period of time to allow
any modif uh requested modifications
on the basis of that percentage change
to be made
the 30 percent alimony formula
took effect on january 1st 2019 as i
said
um prior to that date divorcing parties
could under the law choose to use the
formula
and many did and um either
by court order or in settlement
negotiations
so if the divorce was effective in 2018
the 30 formula works as the new tax law
continues alimony deductibility for
those cases
another provision adds the impact of
federal tax law
on the parties that's a quote impact of
federal tax law on the parties if that's
gets added to the list of special
circumstances
that judges may use uh to
uh make adjustments to the formula so if
there were some
unfairness uh resulting from the
taxability the courts would have the
authorization to excuse me to make such
modifications
and it also clarifies that any
modifications of alimony orders
may be retroactive to the date the other
party received notice of the
modification petition
this just is a technical issue that
clarifies and makes
this law consistent with other similar
support laws
that it a modification can be made but
only back to the date that the
modification was
requested and the other party was
notified in that
um this bill also makes very clear that
the
original alimony statute for the 2001
that went into effect on january 1st
applies only to divorces filed in 2019
and not to prior cases
uh or modifications that were filed
before january 1st 2019 and it
adds a provision on retroactivity on any
alimony
modification that mirrors
uh child support
law about modification so that
it kind of outlines generally
what each of the provisions in this bill
provides
and um i i i'd be
happy to take any questions uh if if
anyone has any but thank you for letting
me
come to um
explain the law and to encourage your
support of it
all right so thank you very much so this
would
basically bring um our current alimony
statute
um in compliance with federal tax laws
correct
correct that is exactly it yes
great um representative long
uh thank you madam chair um
so miss mahoney uh would this
apply for any would this scenario still
apply for any
further tax law change that would um
that would uh have the payer
paying more because of the tax liability
um
do you understand the question not
really i'm sorry
yeah so i'm wondering if if the tax law
changes again
would we have to modify this statute
or or does this
sort of carry over to whatever whatever
um whatever the tax law changes are
well it would depend on what the change
would be
but uh the inclusion of the language
that i mentioned
that the court can take into
consideration
any um tax implications
um i think provides some
flexibility given the passage of timing
so if there were some dramatic change
let's say a return to the
deductibility of alimony to the payor
um there would have we'd have to return
to change that percentage again
precisely for the same reasons why we're
here now however
the the
in the meantime because of the amount of
time it takes to
amend a bill or to ch amend a statute
the court would have the the ability
to take that into consideration
thank you
are there any further questions for miss
mahoney
i need i see no further hands okay
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you for allowing me to testify
okay
that's those are the only two people
that signed up in testimony
is did anybody want to testify in the
audience that
has not had the opportunity i do not see
any hands going up i've seen that
so i will be closing the um public
hearing
on sb16 and there were four signed in
support and one signed in an opposition
and we will be back at 10 30.
thank you
you saw the email from where you're on
the other side
on this bill i'm 93. oh
i mean if she's on the thing okay hold
on one second
what's the name
yes he just sent us an email saying that
she doesn't want to testify
and uh she's thinks that the opportunity
is closed
tell her
hey madam chair
representative desimone
oh i do you know if we're going to be
exacting any uh bills today
well i was gonna text you in just a
minute because it seems to me we could
probably
accept the one we just did okay great
yep
okay
hi everybody is everybody still there
representative ella could you get the
paperwork ready to exec
sb7 16 because i think we can we can get
this one done right away
give you a few minutes we don't have to
do it right at the moment i need
everybody to
come back anyways but let's be sixteen
yeah the one we just did yes yeah
we're gonna go ahead and exact that once
yeah it's good i mean
um they have a few questions as i'm sure
we all will but you know
yeah um just i just have to wait for
everybody to come back because i sent
them all away until 10 30.
so we may have to wait until the end but
[Music]
do we want to do another protocol no
just make sure that cameras have to be
on anyways
yes so
that's why i'm waiting because i could
tell everyone i see them back here 10
dirty so
yeah it can get ready
right
um
one two three four five
oh
things
yeah it's like it didn't make sex there
was nothing like that and
very very much i hadn't even checked yes
so that's good to know
i'll let them know and ask for a better
location
you know how much mileage it's going to
be
thank you madam chair
yes oh yes ma'am
may i assume that the two people that
spoke
did have a written testimony
uh mr bossy didn't but he was basically
just introducing the bill
uh marilyn mahoney i believe
did i'm sorry i forgot to ask oh
it's okay she generally does but i
didn't want to interrupt her
i took notes as well but just
okay i'll look for um
[Music]
the sp sb16 i
i don't see any from marilyn mahoney but
now look i didn't get nina from her yeah
i don't think that we had written
testimony from her
okay representative i didn't have
written testimony but what i had was
drawn from the
senate judiciary committee report on the
bill
and i could have jenny horgan send that
to you if you'd like that would be great
but the rest of the members of the
committee
if you are back and you are listening
can you please turn your cameras on
so that we can continue to exec
house bill i'm sorry senate bill
16. as soon as you turn your cameras
back on
we can move on thank you i just don't
think they're there because i told them
yeah three more two more
we're just we're gonna have to go to the
public hearing
so i just tried putting the address in
google maps and it literally says
address i know i was like i'm not joking
right so like i just he said completely
factual
he sent me an email about it i tapped on
the email
address and it brings me to steven
it brings me to a different address yeah
all right i will get this sorted out i
promise
okay
here here
yeah i just stayed as a panelist so i
think i'm all set for when you need me
okay
two minutes
madam chair it's 10 30.
okay i have 10 29 so i was just trying
to
oh okay
att
my phone says 1029 also
10 30.
okay good morning everyone
we are back so i am now going to open
the public hearing on sb 93
and i will call on rand
bossie thank you madam chair and members
of the committee i am grant bosse
majority policy director for the new
hampshire senate here again
on behalf of senator sharon carson the
prime sponsor of senate bill 93 who is
off
introducing other bills in other
committees at this time
and she again thanks to you for your
indulgence this bill grew out of a
legislative study committee that was
convened in 2019 it's also the
recommendation of the new hampshire
model court project and it would bring
some clarity to the permanence process
under the child protection act
specifically the bill clarifies that
adoption
rather than the termination of parental
rights is a potential permanency plan
objective clarifies the timing of the
12-month permanency hearing
and specifies other circumstances for
which a subsequent perm
permanency hearing may be conducted in
some cases it allows for an
earlier permanency hearing if the
parents are in compliance
and the unique needs of the child to
present circumstances
that justify it and it also gives the
court
the ability to modify a permanency plan
by agreement
at a post permanency hearing this would
bring
clarity and permanence to the adoption
process
benefiting children and their adoptive
families and we ask the
committee for its consideration thank
you very much
great thank you very much mr bossie
next up judge ashley was supposed to um
testify unfortunately she is
unavailable today but she does have
written testimony that was emailed to
all of us
so i would encourage you all to um
please
look at that and we also have richard
head here just in case any questions
come up for the judiciary
representative
um yes do we have an email i'm not sure
if she's in the waiting room but um
the office of the child advocate maura
o'neil
emailed us saying that she had tried to
register to speak
but the registration was closed so if
she's in the waiting room
she would like to present her testimony
thank you i know that
thank you okay great thank you madam
chair she has not yet been
i know i have other people to call on
you guys really i have this under
control
i just wanted to let you know
she's just presenting it for senator
carson
um when we get to questions that we need
for the court
then we will i will ask um mr head if
someone else cannot answer it for us
okay okay so
up next we have rebecca ross
to testify and support um and she is
with
dcyf so can you pull over rebecca ross
for us uh yes i can
here you are
members of the committee madam chair
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony this morning
in support of senate bill 93
um as introduced this was um
arose out of recommendations from a
study committee and was a collaborative
effort with the model court
and representatives of all disciplines
that are engaged
in child protection hearings um
judge ashley's written testimony does a
phenomenal job of
summarizing the different parts of the
bill and i'm not going to
walk through each of the parts although
i'm happy to take questions
on on any of them if members have them
um we are in support of this bill
because we believe
it better meets the needs of children
and family who are involved in the child
protection system
it provides um clarity in the process
both at the beginning phase and at the
end of the permanency
process and explains what to do when the
unique needs of the
child and family don't fit within the
cookie
cutter 12-month permanency hearing
process
if the bill is about
meeting their needs early if efforts are
not being made
that the child can move on through
permanency
and ultimately adoption um if
if that is what is appropriate and gives
the court
direction on work and when those
hearings
will occur and what the burden is for
those hearings
that was one of the driving factors in
the study committee last year looking at
whether or not
the 12-month permanency hearing was
appropriate
so we addressed the the committee's
needs with providing for
a limited exception for early permanency
hearings as well as
providing detail on the process for the
other end
when we get to the 12-month mark and
whether it's that the folks are almost
there
and reunification looks like a
reasonable outcome
or whether um it's because of the unique
needs of the child
that permanent or reunification has not
been achieved yet the court will now
have direction
on providing um one limited extension
for a permanency hearing in order to
allow
the court and dcyf to meet the
the best interest of the child um
this is particularly good timing to make
these changes and revamp this permanency
process because it corresponds with all
of the other
changes that the legislature has
supported to the to the service delivery
system
including um more preventative services
through community-based voluntary
services
as well as the system of care changes
for children's behavioral health which
will be able to step in
for those cases where it's the unique
needs of the child preventing
reunification
at the the far end of that 12-month
process
so we believe that all of the changes in
this bill are appropriate
will provide clarity and consistency
through our courts and to our families
and um is consistent with
the the service delivery changes that
are being made and will be very helpful
in supporting families accessing those
services and meeting the best interests
of children
and i'm happy to take questions at any
time great thank you very much
representative belanger uh thank you
madam chair
i thank you uh miss ross for your
testimony this
uh this good morning thanks trying to
get ahead of myself here
um in the case where
does this in your opinion does this bill
reflectively respond only to cases in
which dcyf is involved
yes this is this is under the child
protection act and would be in an abuse
neglect case that the division
is a party too okay thank you
all right are there any further
questions for miss ross
okay seeing none thank you very much
okay up next will be marcia sink
to um speak in support of the bill
and she is with casa of new hampshire
missing can you unmute
i'm sorry sorry about that good morning
good morning thank you madam chair and
thank you members of the committee
my name is marsha sink and i am the ceo
of casa of new hampshire
and i've been with casa since its
inception in 1989.
casa is statutorily mandated to serve as
guardian ad litem
on cases of child abuse and neglect in
fiscal year 2020
630 casa volunteer guardian zed litem
advocated for 1450 of our state's abused
and neglected children
casa fully supports senate bill 93
judge ashley's written testimony
explains quite well the proposed changes
to the statute
which will better support children and
families as it continues to encourage
timely permanency for children and youth
whose best interest is paramount
casa supports the bill and it's entirely
but i'd like to focus on the impact
of extensions and delays and how this
bill addresses
the necessity to allow at times and
with limits uh those extensions and
all too often we see significant delays
in permanency
for children and the damage and
additional trauma our system can inflict
on these already traumatized children
and youth as they wait for closure
even when children and youth are in
their pre-adoptive homes
we have seen disrupted placements as
these victims wait for months
or years for the court and the parties
to
come to final decisions about their
lives waiting to be adopted
or waiting to go home last june i had
the opportunity to virtually
attend a nashua area celebration of
reunification
it was attended by dcauif workers
supervisors casa volunteers and others
but most importantly it was attended by
families that had been
successfully reunified i'll never forget
i mean this has just stuck with me one
mom on this zoom
call with her two children sort of
hanging over her shoulders
who were laughing and smiling so they
could get their faces into the screen
to be seen and this mom called out judge
leary who took the time to be with them
that evening
and she said to judge leary if you had
not given me
more time i would not be sitting here
right now with my children home with me
and this was an example of how one mom
working hard in recovery
was given the additional time and
enabled the opportunity for her children
to come home
we believe that it's in the best
interest of our casa kids as we call
them to be entitled
to the reassurance that this bill will
provide for timely permanency
one little nine-year-old boy whose case
had been open for several years
said to his casabob you better hurry up
and get me adopted because i'm not going
to be cute much longer
when reunification is not the plan then
seemingly endless days
to children waiting can cause
irreparable and permanent harm
timely permanency is critical to the
well-being of children and their
families and senate bill 93 will provide
clarification in the statute and
specific guidance to the courts
and all parties regarding just how long
we can allow children
to linger in a place of uncertainty
thank you i'm happy to take any
questions well thank you very much for
that testimony are there any
questions from miss sink
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you
up next is suzelle juarez
i hope i didn't butcher that name too
badly
um to speak um on behalf of herself
and she is neutral and is asked for
three minutes
uh good morning madam chair and members
of the committee
i'm so sorry man i'm sure i thought i
had uh registered in support
i must have clicked the wrong the wrong
selection i'm so sorry about that
um good morning members of the committee
my name is susel jarrez
and i am speaking to you today in
support of senate bill 93
um just a little bit about myself i am a
master of social work student at the
university of new hampshire
and i also work for the mental health
center of greater manchester however
today i am speaking
um as a citizen um actually
in the interest of time missing talk
touched upon a lot of my
points that i was going to bring to you
today
um so just to reiterate some very
important
um points that she made
senate bill 93 does an incredible job at
clarifying compelling reasons
as to why early permanency or extensions
can be important in permanency hearings
a study conducted in 2018 found that
over 37
000 youths are emancipated from the from
the foster care system
without any kind of permanency plan the
study also talked about the impacts that
this has on the mental health of
children and youth in our system
as they wait you know
an endless amount of time whether that's
months or a year
or even the 12 months even that's
12 months that children are in our
system wondering
what their future looks like and a lot
of these children
feel hopeless at times especially as
they begin to age
um because unfortunately there is this
thought and a stigma around the fact
that
older youth are unadoptable
in these cases i think early permanency
hearings can make a great difference in
the mental health
of our children and youth in the state
of new hampshire and i urge you to take
that into consideration
um no one wants to be taken out of an
abuse or neglect situation just to feel
neglected by the system that's
there to support them um so
i thank you for your time today i don't
want to take up too much of your time as
i said missing did touch upon a lot of
the points i was going to make
i strongly urge you to vote in support
of senate bill 93
um thank you i welcome questions great
thank you very much
are there any questions
all right seeing them thank you very
much for your testimony
up next um will be moira o'neil
the new hampshire child advocate
the director of the office of the new
hampshire child advocate
miss o'neil good morning thank you madam
chair and members of the committee i'm
sorry to make a bit of a fuss to have
you hear me today i appreciate you
taking the time i'm
for the record moira o'neil i am new
hampshire's child advocate
and i'm happy to speak in support of
senate bill 93
relative to permanency planning under
the child protection act
we do absolutely support the bill i
don't think i can add
to the eloquence of mahdi singh from
casa new hampshire and what this means
in terms of the concept of permanency
i will point out that one of my staff
noticed last summer
in the midst of all the angst around
covert 19
that our experience of the pandemic and
the lockdown
was very much like the experience of a
child awaiting permanency
we now know all about the impact of
being separated from loved ones and not
knowing what's going to happen
next and so i hope that we use that
shared experience to inform decisions
going forward
as i said we do support the bill um and
its intent for smooth
uh transitions when natural parents are
unable or unwilling to be parents
um we do however want to take advantage
of your time if you'll be so generous to
just make
one comment on something that we're we
we have a concern and we want to share
should this bill pass and become part of
the legal fabric of families lives
we want to urge the division for
children youth and families
the courts casa gal providers foster
families
and all those that are involved in the
lives of children who are removed from
their parents to be mindful
of the extent of loss involved when
terminated
when parents rights are terminated
permanency
shouldn't be exclusive of important
relationships
in the office of the child advocate
we've observed children who had
meaningful relationships with parents
who were just
unable to parent the office of the child
advocate recently released a system
learning review summary on four
children's cases including the case of
joseph
joseph lost a deep relationship with his
mother who visited him regularly
and whom he never saw again after her
rights were terminated
he later lost a relationship with a
foster mother and then his aunt and
uncle well we don't disagree that those
four people may not have been able to
meet his needs as permanent caregivers
they did and still do mean something to
him
he's left with trying to understand
whether they failed him or he failed
them
so these relationships in whatever form
they might end up being
are integral to a child's self-worth and
ability to bond with others
one of the most common calls that we
receive at the office of the child
advocate is from a grandparent
aunt or uncle who just want to be a part
of a child's life
often they have strong bonded
relationships with the child
some are fighting to be parents when
actually they would be best
suited to remain the child's grandparent
or aunt or uncle
unfortunately those opportunities are
rare
so we understand that you cannot
legislate
or force relationships amongst families
and foster
adoptive families however we would be
remiss if we didn't take this request
and put it on record that as we take a
close look at the law
to be sure children are able to rest in
permanency
that the people who influence children's
relationships do whatever they can to
promote
and support the salvaging of relative
relative relationships in whatever form
in the best interest of children so the
office of child advocate urges the
committee to pass senate bill 93
and we also asked consideration from
those involved to be sure
the importance of family relationships
for children in all decisions rendered
on their behalf so thank you very much
for giving me that time to
just say that i'm happy to take
questions if you have them
thank you very much miss o'neill i i
have to agree with your points
thank you for bringing those up um any
questions for
uh miss o'neal representative lewicki
thank you madam chair thank you ms
o'neill
one of the things i'm not really
familiar with the process and if you
could give a brief overview of how the
schedule works and so forth
it might be very helpful to me and
possibly other members of the committee
thank you so much for that question i
really regret that judge ashley wasn't
available today
and i would refer you to her testimony
as she understands the
details of it and can explain it so much
better
in general there's when a child comes
into care there's
there's an expectation for permanency
within 12 months
and so what this law does is give some
flexibility
sometimes for that 12 months to be
shorter
and sometimes for that to be longer
the the 12 months is based on sort of
the idea around the developmental needs
of a child the bonding
relationships necessary for children um
and the idea that permanency is so
important
unfortunately it doesn't always align
with
treatment um schedules so the
the the availability of someone to be
ready for
say for example substance use treatment
um to be willing and able and to access
services
sometimes don't align with that and may
take longer
there are also times when um it's very
clear that
a child's not going to be able to be
reunited with a with parents because of
incarceration
or severe illness or or other factors
and in that case that child may be
waiting for a long period of time
for that decision to make because of the
expectation around the 12 months
so this just gives a little bit of
flexibility in the courts so that
um all of those persons who are working
in the best interest of the child will
be able to
make that child feel as though they
they're at home
and um and they have some permanency
thank you great thank you very much are
there any further questions for miss
o'neill
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you so much okay so i'm going to
close the pairing on scp-93
we're going to take a quick five-minute
break so that the clerk can get ready so
that we can exact um because we have
time before the next hearing
so let's exec sb16 and sb93 but i need
five minutes
but hear me i apologize i didn't have my
mic on
[Music]
we're good okay so you just give me five
minutes please
you
thank you okay everyone i'm gonna call
everyone back i'll give everyone a few
minutes
to come back to turn their cameras on so
that we can
accept sb16 and sb93
and as a reminder in order to vote your
camera has to be on
yes ma'am chair okay good um
representative al chiller a minute
excuse me madam chair yes
i just wanted to let you know that i am
in my home
at this point in time and i am in the
room alone
great thank you very much
okay so i'm going to open the executive
session
on sb 16
amending the alimony statute which in my
you know is basically a formality
does anyone have any further discussion
on it
looking for hands raised
okay well i i don't see any so
madam clerk can you call oh never mind
um representative
phone do you have a motion instead of
chair
i'd like to make a motion of otp
on senate bill 16.
representative bolandra seconds that
is there any further discussion
um representative there we go okay
all right i don't see any further
discussion so i will ask the clerk to
call the role
i'm vice chair representative desimone
yes
madam chair yes representative
rice yes
representative yokela
yes
representative wiki yes
representative belanger yeah
it's representative cross come in
no
representative litchfield yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes
representative alicea yes
representative grossman
yes representative levay
yes
representative way there
yes representative petrygno
yes representative art schiller
without objection sp 16 will be placed
on the
consent calendar
okay and i will give um
adam clark a minute to get ready for
sb 93.
so just give her a minute
just let me know when you're ready i'm
good
okay i'm going to open the executive
session
on sb 93 and recognize representative
desimone
thank you madam chair madam chair i move
ought to pass on senate bill 93
fm thank you
seconded by representative belanger
there um
further discussion on sb 93.
i would just like to say i really like
this bill and it's not because i'm a
co-sponsor so um
[Music]
all right seeing no further discussions
i'll have the clerk call her all
vice chair of representative desimone
vice chair representative de simone yes
madam chair representative rice
yes representative
jokila sorry
yes
[Music]
yes i'm sorry
yes thank you
representative cross is not here
representative litchfield
yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes
representative ali sayeth yes
representative grossman yes
representative levine
yes
representative vazir yes
representative petrigano yes
representative offshore yes
madam chair the vote is 14 years
zero nays great thank you but that
cannot go
on consent due to the fiscal note
okay so we have about 12 minutes before
our next public hearing so we'll see you
back here
probably at 11 15. thank you
that's okay
all right okay everyone we have one
minute
so if people could stop meandering back
to their computers that'd be great
i do not see is grant still on here
grand bossy
i do not see him
okay oh wait there's senator carson okay
so we're good
all right okay friends it
is 11 15.
so i'm going to open the public hearing
on sb
94 relative to juvenile diversion
programs and i will call on
senator sharon carson
go here we go good morning madam chair
and good morning
house children and family law committee
for the record my name is sharon carson
and i have the pleasure of representing
senate district 14
comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn
and i have this morning for your
consideration senate bill 94
which seeks to clarify the procedure for
obtaining a needs assessment
through juvenile diversion prior to
proceeding with a
delinquency petition under rsa 169b
this bill was filed at the request of
the
juvenile justice transformation group
this was a team that was formed in
november of 2019
through a federal grant and the team
went to georgetown university
to learn about the latest in juvenile
justice
the team included director ribson
two other members of the juvenile
justice staff at dcys
new hampshire new hampshire child
advocate
a judge and the and the chair of the
juvenile diversion program the
publisher's defender's office
and a prosecutor this bill is one step
of the plan that has been formed out of
the work of this team
the bill requires uh law enforcement and
prosecutors
to refer youth for a needs assessment
prior to filing a delinquency petition
except in cases that involve the most
serious offense the proposed assessment
is voluntary and is meant to allow the
department
to identify the needs of youth prior to
court
involvement the goal of this legislation
is to lower court involvement with the
use of appropriate
community service and this is also
to be seen as an extension of our
current system of care
and so really what we'd want to do is
try to get
these kids that are are in difficult
situations
services prior to involving the court
so with that madam chair i will end my
testimony
and um i unfortunately i have to get
back
to uh house edna on an autonomous bill
so i'm going to ask to defer the
questions i'm sure
that there are a lot of people who would
like to speak on this bill so i
appreciate your
your time this morning and wish everyone
well
thank you senator by any chance did you
have written testimony to submit
no i did not okay great thank you very
much have a great day
you too thank you
okay up next is michael skivy
to speak in support of the bill and he's
asked for five minutes could you please
state your name where you're from
and whether or not you have written
testimony
good morning madam chair michael skibby
from the disability rights center
i do not have written testimony and i'll
just testify briefly
this is a bill that um um i think
um well let me let me just stop for a
moment and and thank
um senator carson uh for her sponsorship
of this bill
um and um i think uh thanks also go to
uh mr ribson and his staff and
the the other members of his of his
working group for reaching out to me
and to other members of the juvenile
reform project such as waypoint and
the aclu and new hampshire legal
assistance a group that i think you're
all familiar with on our juvenile reform
efforts
they um engaged with us in i think a
very
constructive and productive way and i
think that the result was
a bill that is deserving of your support
it's certainly
something that i support um i think that
that
one of the challenges of of um of
juvenile justice
is sort of a paradox that um as the
system reform
as the system responds to um misconduct
on the part of youth
um it it oftentimes um
makes things worse not better um through
no bad intention but
the the fact of the matter is is that
the more deeply
um a child gets pulled into the juvenile
delinquency system
um the more uh often um the recidivism
rate goes up not down
and you know oftentimes that is most
apparent when you're talking about very
minor offenses
the more formal the and um
and firm if you will the response on the
part of law enforcement on the part of
courts on the part of
uh the other elements of the system uh
the more likely it is that the child
will um
will return again and again um
oftentimes that's because of
self-labeling
oftentimes it's because of stigma in
their community
oftentimes it's because of the weakening
of protective
connections that are extremely important
for
children who are at risk of future
delinquency
and so it's very important if possible
and if it can be done safely
to have as therapeutic response as
possible
and to have that response be outside the
court and
the other elements of the formal justice
system and i think senate bill 94 does
that and it and it effectively balances
the needs of the formal system
uh with the treatment needs of of the
system and what it's really trying to
accomplish in terms of therapeutic
responses
um i won't go into detail into sort of
describing the
the bill i'm sure that mr ribson or one
of one of his colleagues will do that
for you but
i think that one of the concerns that we
had was to make sure that
if early in a child's
encounter with uh with law enforcement
and with
the juvenile justice system they're
being asked questions about their
treatment needs there are certain risks
that come with that
that can be important for the fairness
of the adjudicatory system that is
you know is a child going to be asked
questions that could later
be used to um against them in court
and and that's a very difficult and
challenging
um issue to deal with in a way that both
gets the information to frame services
um in an accurate and effective way but
also protects the child's rights
if in fact the formal system proceeds
and i think that this bill does that
very effectively
and again i want to thank mr ripson and
his colleagues for
being willing to engage on that issue
and other issues that
were of concern to us i'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you
great thank you very much representative
long
thank you uh thank you madam chair uh
mr skippy do you have the bill in front
of you by any chance i do
um i i'm not sure if you'd be the one
answered or maybe
mr ripson but uh when you look on page
uh
when you look on page 2 line 15
yes the the department shall obtain the
consent of the minor
and the miner's parent and guardian then
when you look at
b and there's two other places in this
bill where it says if the miner
or the miner's parent does not consent
do you see a possible misunderstanding
where it first starts off saying
both need to consent and then it's
um it leaves it up to one or the other
do i see that as a as a practical
problem is that the question
yes um well i can certainly imagine
circumstances where
um that could be challenging
um and and i suppose you know i think
we would all have to live with um the
one
the one possibility which is that the
minor
um wants to go one way and the parents
want to go the other and the
the parent have to remain in the
driver's seat in within with regard
let's say that the minor
objects and the parents want to proceed
or let me put it the other way the minor
the minor
um doesn't want to proceed with the but
the parents want to proceed
i think that that's pretty problematic
um
well let me just let me start over i
think that one of the problems that we
have is that
for this for this process to work um you
have to live with
the sort of tradition and the legal um
framework that we have that minors um
are really subject to the wishes of
their parents or guardian and so you
can't
subject a minor to involuntary medical
treatment without the consent of
of the parent or guardian or an
assessment without the consent of the
parent regard and i just think i don't
think there's any way around that
unless you're part of some sort of
legal proceeding so i think that's
really the problem
um but it would be unfortunate if
um if the parents
are wanting well i can i can imagine
circumstances where
where there would be a lot of
frustration about you know the parents
wanting to proceed the system wanting to
proceed
and because the minor's objections it's
not going to go forward
okay uh thank you
are there any further questions for mr
skivy
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
i'm going to go a little out of order
right now so that we can um
hear from um joe ribson the director
of dcyf because i think he he um
or mrs ross may be able to answer um
questions for us so um director rip some
great thank you uh madam chair
uh can everybody hear me yes wonderful
uh joe ripson for the record joe ripson
director of dcyf
i am in my office in concord alone um
just a bit of warning they're doing work
on our fire
alarm system today so hopefully that
won't happen in the middle of
my testimony but it could um
and thank you senator carson and thank
you representative belanger for bringing
this forward for us this is really
important work i'm very very grateful to
the host of stakeholders who have been
involved in this process and very very
grateful to the host of stakeholders
who are going to continue to be involved
in this process this is just one part of
a
of a of a very ambitious project to
really kind of
redefine the way the juvenile justice
works in this state and we're trying to
do it by including
um all the voices that have a stake in
this you know parents and family voice
youth voice all of the professional
stakeholders
um and that's not always easy sometimes
folks have disagreements about some of
these things and we
we try to wrestle with them but we're
trying to take all concerns seriously
and move forward in a way that
that makes sense for everybody so
as uh representative cars or as senator
carson shared this bill was
um crafted by the what we're calling the
juvenile justice transformation group
which was a
group of folks who in november of 2019
were awarded a grant to join a project
down at georgetown university with the
support of the annie e casey foundation
for the purpose of really thinking about
juvenile probation and what works and
what doesn't work
and for the purpose of you know really
trying to make sure that
kids who end up in that system are the
kids who need that system and that there
are lots of kids who don't need that
depth of intervention who could be
served in a
in a more voluntary um more voluntary
fashion without having to get deeply
into that system it's smart for kids
i think it makes it makes kids have
better outcomes but it's also smart from
a resource perspective where you
uh currently have a lot of kids going
through the formal system who probably
didn't need to be there
and that takes up attorney time it takes
up precious bench time which is a
commodity that's that's hard to find
across um
our state and it takes up time of
juvenile probation staff
and you know what this bill seeks to do
is to kind of shift
part of the role of our juvenile
probation staff to make them more
proactive and preventative in their work
instead of having to only be reactive to
court cases so now let me go into a
little bit about what this bill
actually you know how this is supposed
to work
um so what this does is it really
quite simply creates a process by which
whenever a child has contact with law
enforcement be it an arrest or not
they don't we don't want to force people
to arrest kids but if they have contact
with law enforcement
law enforcement may refer to the
department to have a strength and needs
assessment conducted
the family and the youth do have to
consent to having that conducted this is
not supposed to be a compulsory thing
it's a way to try to voluntarily get
kids out of the system
we will then conduct that assessment and
we'll make a recommendation as to
whether there's community-based services
that could help
things like fast-forward perhaps if
there's a behavioral health intervention
that needs to be provided or even a
voluntary case with
juvenile justice there's what we call
voluntary chins which don't have to go
through the formal court process but
allows
families and youth to access all the
services that dcyf can pay for and
provide if they're clinically
appropriate
so the idea is to conduct that voluntary
assessment and then at the end of that
voluntary assessment
we'll provide a recommendation back to
the referring entity typically a law
enforcement prosecution
about you know what types of services
we've recommended and whether we
recommend
that a formal case needs to continue to
be filed and move forward
it's really important to note that
that's not it's a recommendation
it's not mandatory nobody you know no
prosecutor is required
to follow our recommendation but they
will have our recommendation um and i do
think that's an important part to
ensure that they have some um some
independence in their decision making as
well
so we're conducting an evaluation we're
making a recommendation
we think for many youth they're gonna
voluntarily engage and be able to be
diverted from the formal system
but if they choose not to and if a
prosecutor decides that for the purposes
of community safety or whatever that
they want to proceed they'll be able to
do that
the other big piece of this is in
addition to that assessment being able
to be used at that front end
to be able to determine whether there
are services that can be provided before
kids go to court
it also is useful if kids actually do go
to court
so what happens today in many many cases
is that kids end up going through court
and the dispositions have been filed
without anybody ever actually assessing
what the kids needs were
and you end up in a situation where
largely attorneys
are making what are clinical decisions
you know whether that be judges or
defense counsel or um prosecutors making
clinical decisions about what kids
really need without ever going through
an assessment
and that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to me um you really need the
advice of the people who understand kids
needs to be able to make those plans
so the other big piece of this is that
when that assessment occurs even if the
kid ends up going through the court
process
that that information could be used to
develop better recommendations for youth
who do need to go through the formal
system
to make sure that the things that we're
providing actually make sense for what
the kids need
again i just want to you know speak a
little bit to representative long's
question around the
um voluntary nature of the
the assessment process it's voluntary
it requires both the parent and the
youth to consent largely for the reasons
that mr skivy put forward
i don't think the two sections are
irreconcilable because
it requires an a that both parties
consent for us to conduct the assessment
and then b it switches to the negative
so if either party objects we cannot
then share that assessment information
further
um so i think i i do think that they're
they can be read together to work as
currently written
um because we're requiring in the first
instance both to consent to start and
then the second instance both to consent
to um to proceed with sharing that
information
as mr skibby pointed out there were some
additional protections put in place
and you know it was never our intent to
use this as a way to get information
from youth to
to be able to have that be used against
them in an adjudicatory process it's
really about identifying needs
um so with the help of mr skibby and
some of the other stakeholders were able
to craft some language to make sure that
you don't have to worry about anything
that a youth discloses
during that assessment process being
used against them in a delinquency
process through the courts
so that information is only allowed to
be used
again with the consent of the youth and
the family
and again this is all really about
identifying needs sooner
getting kids what they need sooner
keeping them from getting deeper into
the system
and with that i'm happy to take any
questions that folks have
great thank you so i have a quick
question uh
27 people signed in in opposition to
this and a lot of them seem to be
from police departments so i'm curious
as to
if you would have because no one signed
up to speak against it
but what their issue would be
with this yeah you know i don't want to
i don't want to speculate too much i
will say
as part of this project we have been um
holding a host of meetings i think i
think representative wong was at some of
them i think um a few other folks were
at some of them as well
um where we've walked through what were
what the plan is
with this work and then had what we
called affinity groups where all the
different stakeholders could come in
groups
like themselves and share their feedback
and we did have some law enforcement
folks
show up at the law enforcement affinity
group who expressed some concerns
um largely around i think frustration
that a lot of the changes that have
taken place in the juvenile justice
system over the past decade have taken
place without their voice at the table
and there might be more specific
concerns than that but that was a lot of
what we heard
and i think a lot of skepticism um
that that this will actually work
um because i think it's one of their
experiences they've not seen
diversion programs be as successful as
as
they'd like them to be and i think you
know again i i don't want to set up a
straw man they can certainly speak
for themselves as to what their concerns
were but that's those are the concerns
that i heard
um and in response to both of those
things i think my
my response would be one we want
everybody at the table
you know we've we've been trying to get
rid of the table there are a host of
sessions coming up about how to
implement this work going forward that
certainly
anybody and everybody who's concerned
can be part of that
in order for us to make sure that this
works and secondarily we're trying
something new that's
not the same as how these things work
today in this state
right so you can't really compare how
the current system works to what we're
talking about doing here
what we're talking about doing here is
is totally new and totally different
and then lastly just to emphasize as i
said in my testimony at the start
nothing that we decide through an
assessment process is going to tie their
hands in terms of what they decide to do
moving forward with the court process
this is about providing alternatives
providing information
and what i think is going to happen is
that we'll find
that those folks who are skeptical will
find that youth are doing better
and at the end of the day they'll be
happy with having another opportunity to
have somebody else take a look at a kid
and try to solve the problem
but change is hard and i think that's
part of what we're hearing
right because we can't we can't be
afraid to try new things
you know then we're just stuck in the
same old ruts
great um okay representative long
[Music]
thank you madam chair um actually that
was one of my questions with respect to
police
it it appeared in the bill that they
had a little more responsibility but
then when i keep rereading it
i mean it appears that they am i correct
joe that they would
uh the arresting officer would revert
this to the agency which is
the uh to to uh health and human
services correct
yeah yep their only responsibility is
that um
they can make a referral for any kid
they come into contact with
and if they think they're go if they
plan to go to court then they shall make
a referral before they go to court
there is an exception for emergency
situations right if you have something
really
extreme that happens for which a kid
requires immediate placement or
detention
they don't need to wait for that process
they can move forward with that and
we'll do the assessment later
um but that's a very very slim
number of the cases that we get the vast
majority of times
um you know kids kids get arrested they
get in trouble and it's a month or so
before the case actually goes to court
and the plan with this is that
this intervention is going to occur
within the first 30 days
so that people have the opportunity to
have this information when they make
their decisions
so yeah their only responsibility is
gonna be to make a referral and then to
get the feedback from us
okay thank you could i get a follow-up
madam chair certainly
uh actually joe do you have the bill in
front of you by any chance
yes uh actually
on my same question that i had with
mr skibby um which i'm
becoming a little more comfortable that
it's not a conflict but
just to be clear on page 3
line 16 it refers to the minor
or the minor's parents or guardian not
consenting to the assessment
do you see i you know
i i just don't want well i you know i
don't want to see a parent coming to us
down a line saying you know my rights
were taken away from me because
i thought this was in the best interest
of my child my child didn't think so
you know um so you don't you don't see
um you don't see an issue with
the beginning it starts with an end and
in two spots it's an
or i i don't think the ends are the ors
are the challenge because the two ors
are where it's a negative right
if either party does not consent it
can't proceed where the first one is an
affirmative in order to start the
process both parties must consent
um i do think the issue they're raising
is something that could happen
right and and that's that's something
that i think is going to have to need to
remain in the bill the idea that we are
requiring
youth and parents to consent and part of
that's because
what we're doing here which is which
isn't entirely natural but it's part of
the evolution of juvenile justice
is that we're kind of overlaying a
treatment model into what's historically
been a correctional model
and in a correctional model right youth
have attorneys and they have rights
um even if parents disagree and i think
that's that's really what's the
discomfort in this space
and maybe someday we move to a place
where the systems are are more treatment
based and those tensions go away but
but as we are in the evolution of a
system today i think we have to
we have to structure in a way that that
keeps youth rights in place
with their council they're they have
attorneys to represent them in these
matters
um as well as parental rights in place
to make these decisions
may i have one more uh amount of chair
yeah
thank you uh now at this point
there's not an attorney assigned correct
because there hasn't been any filing
with the courts
am i correct in that yeah at the point
of the initial assessment there would be
no counsel yet assigned okay
okay thank you yep and that's part of
the reason why we put this later consent
provision in before it can go to court
um to to address that situation right i
think an ideal system without regard to
cost you would have an attorney assigned
at the point of an assessment but that
would really drive up
the cost of a bill and you know i
wouldn't be opposed to that but that's a
that's another that's a much bigger
issue i think
right for the state so okay thank you
thank you representative wiki uh thank
you madam chair
uh mr ribson already answered my
question when he was
answering uh representative okay great
thank you
all right are there any further
questions from mr ribson
[Music]
thank you very much joe great thank you
everyone
okay up next is um pamela jones from the
new hampshire public
defender's office to speak in support of
the bill
for five minutes could you please state
your name where you're from and
whether or not you have written
testimony good morning
can you all hear me yes great
i am pamela jones i am from the new
hampshire public defender the nashua
office
i'm currently in my home office by
myself
um thank you for having me i'm really
grateful to be able to be here and speak
i should tell the court i mean
i'm used to talking to the court i'm
sorry i should tell all of you that i
am a member of the transforming
probation team that joe was referring to
um i have been a public defender for
nearly 13 years
my practice has been primarily
concentrated in juvenile defense
and i have been a liaison such as being
on the transforming team
to other stakeholders to include the
department of health and human services
the office of the child advocate the
courts
the office the new hampshire legal
assistance and the disability rights
center we all
are working towards a common purpose of
improving services for juveniles
and new hampshire public defender
supports all initiatives with that
agenda
we support the passing of sb 94 in
particular
because the goal of sb 94 is to decrease
the number of system-involved youth to
divert
formally and informally youth away from
the system
to offer services that are indeed
individualized and
to the youth specific needs for those
reasons we support the bill
we support it because it comes from a
place of understanding adolescent brain
development
and and that youths brains are not fully
developed until they are 25
making them less culpable and more
likely
to grow out of behavior that leads to
delinquency
we know that keeping kids out of the
juvenile justice system
makes it so they grow into mature
law-abiding adults as opposed
to higher recidivism rates that we've
seen for kids who are in the system
sb 94 provides for kids who must come
into the system and who do need services
to have an assessment that will inform
all of those needs
and strengths of the youth and result
hopefully in a more developmentally and
individualized plan for the youth
the hope is through sb 94 and the
collection of data
that the racial inequities that are that
are apparent in the juvenile justice
system will be addressed
as we know black and brown youth are
over represented in the system
across the board from the point of
arrest to disposition and commitment to
sysc
for all of these reasons the public
defender
supports the passing of sb 94. i support
the passing of sb94
thank you thank you and and did you have
written testimony
i'm sorry i do not have written
testimony okay thank you
uh representative long has a question
certainly
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
for your
due diligence on this uh thank you for
your involvement
uh absolutely
the ac applicability um is there a
reason why
where you know it goes from
january of 22 to july of 22 to october
of 22 for different courts is was there
some reasoning behind that i i think if
i'm
if i'm correct on this and of course joe
can um answer this better
but i don't think he's still here but um
the idea was
that this is a lot to implement um it's
going to take a lot of
details and so the thought was that we
would implement it slowly and we would
start in one you know one place to the
next to the next
and really it's simply about
implementation you know to make it
smooth and frankly i think the the
places that were contemplated were
because there are heavy juvenile dockets
there are very involved juvenile judges
in those
areas and you know they will be ready to
take this on and so then it
will figure out the kinks and then when
we get to the other courts it'll be
much smoother at that point so i think i
believe that was the primary reasoning
for that
okay thank you you're welcome
i think that was a good reason yes
honestly are there any further questions
all right saying none thank you very
much miss jones thank you
up next is richard head
um please state your name where you're
from and if you have written testimony
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee my name is richard head
i'm the government affairs coordinator
for the new hampshire judicial branch
um i don't have anything specific to say
other than we support the
the bill as written we apologize that
judge ashley had a family emergency and
was unable to
participate in both this and the prior
hearing but
if there are questions i'd be happy to
try to research them but
we just wanted to say we support the
bill as presented thank you i'd be happy
to answer any questions or
at least try to in judge ashley's
absence
okay are there any questions for mr head
all right oh representative
take long out of chair just just it
would be helpful because i'm looking
at the aqua um when they go into an
effect and i see manchester has
one of the last ones um you know which
is okay but i'm wondering mr head if you
would have
uh case numbers i mean you know
the amount of cases in the nine circuits
because i'm thinking maybe that's why
they separated it too
uh because i see nashua has one of the
first so there's probably a lot of
caseload there
um so would you have that by
i mean not today but could the committee
get that breakdown i can certainly um
uh see what i can get for you and and
get that to the committee we do also
have
um some number of statistics on our um
on the website so it may just be
publicly available too but either which
way i will get you either a link or the
data
um regarding number of cases okay thank
you
representative long if you like i can
see if director rips and
come back on so he can answer that that
question for you
you know that that that'd be great
because i i
you know i i don't even know if they can
get a number
um because this is unique you know
they've got to agree to assessments and
all that stuff so
okay so represent so are there any
further questions for mr head
okay see none thank you very much mr
head and i'm going to call
director ribson back up so that he can
address representative long's questions
he is unmuted yeah you're unmuted
director great thank you madam chair um
yes i don't have the exact numbers in
front of me although probably in five
minutes i could pull up some numbers
um i just have to go into our data
system um but yes
the part of the rationale for for the
rollout was
as as ms jones explained um one having
appropriate time to implement it in
different places um part of this
is we're shifting the role of some of
our staff so staff who historically have
only done probation and parole
oversight for open court cases are going
to move into this new role of doing
these assessments up front
and we're we're counting on the reality
that we're going to have fewer deep end
cases meaning we have more
workforce to do the front-end work right
so we have to move it over time so that
we can shift staff
from one end of the system to the other
end of the system and then
so that was the reason why we had to
implement slowly over time
i mean it's not that slowly it's over i
think three different quarters
but then the the choice of where to set
that up was based on
uh making sure of a couple different
things um
one that we weren't overwhelming the
system by having you know the two
biggest parts of the state combined at
the same time which would be as you
alluded to nashua and manchester
um and two the places where it seemed
like we had
um the easiest choosing for the very
first one the places where we seemed
that we had the easiest collaboration
between public defenders
prosecutors jppos courts
who were kind of naturally on the same
page around this
so that we can kind of test it out with
them work out the kinks with them before
we rolled into other places
um where maybe those relationships
weren't quite as strong yet um so those
were the reasons
although i like i said at the end of the
day i think this is i think this is
going to be good for everybody
but um we tried to structure in a way
that it would be successful and didn't
just
just open up the doors and not be ready
for it
okay great thank you so much does that
does that help you out
representative long it does immensely
thank you
right thanks okay up next
is um moira o'neil the director of the
office of the child advocate
thank you madam chair um thank you
committee for um
for hearing my testimony for the record
my name is moira o'neil
i am the new hampshire state child
advocate and i am happy to support
senate bill 94 relative to juvenile
diversion programs i am also a member of
the juvenile
transformation team um and just to give
you a little context
since we all went together to washington
dc pre pandemic for an entire week
the most intensive week of my life of
training and education
we have been meeting sometimes three and
four times a week
since then working on this project and
it's been a phenomenally
interdisciplinary process
and we've come to really appreciate both
each other and um and the the commitment
for this
for for the for the broader
transformation of juvenile justice so
i'm very pleased to be able to support
this bill um and
i just want to emphasize a little bit
that senate bill
94 is about prevention it provides for a
child to obtain this
voluntary strengths-based needs
assessment before the petition is filed
um and just to give a little context
when it when a child breaks a law or a
rule
there are potentially four conditions
one it may be youthful in discretion
which is more about immaturity than
criminality
um there may be developmental disability
or mental illness which is about
disruption and development or an illness
and a resulting
incapacity for the insight about what
the child's doing
there may be adverse childhood
experiences in which children's actions
are influenced by the adverse factors
of their lives such as poverty hunger
exposure to substance abuse and family
dysfunction
and there may be a social pathology or
an intentional criminology which is
actually fairly rare amongst young
young children so under senate bill 94
a police officer can still address
youthful indiscretion by counseling that
child and sending them home
to his parents um and you know for
lessons learned
but for those children who are not
immediately sent home with disability
or an adverse influence will be
identified in this assessment process
and through that process solutions will
be sorted out to best help the child in
the family
whether it will be clinical help
educational help or perhaps some
targeted
social supports and i want to emphasize
that the purpose of assessing
needs is to determine whether if you
mitigate that need
you can also mitigate the risk of the
child's behavior towards the community
so this
is an essentially a sort of law
enforcement effort and that we're trying
to make sure that
um when children's needs are met so that
they're so that they're not at risk for
society
and while probation may feel intuitively
like it's going to stop
problem behavior what we've learned in
the past year and a half
is that it actually doesn't um in
any involvement in fact in the juvenile
justice system is a primary indicator of
reoffending
of poor school performance and of other
negative outcomes
in fact children who are diverted from
the system are far less likely to be
suspended from school
so when their needs are met the
incidence of reoffending is lowered
and this is consistent with what you've
heard from me
about children's brain development and
past hearings
and attorney joan jones mentioned that
brain development
is in the context of culpability that
children don't understand
but equally as important is the
malleability of the child's brain
means that they can learn and they can
adjust their antisocial behavior in the
right conditions so we're trying to
create the right conditions for these
kids
and as you also know and i think that
attorney skippy mentioned
about the majority of children coming
into the system
more not because of serious offenses but
because of a lack of understanding about
their needs or the inability to access
services
you know there's too many kids in the
system who have mental health disorders
identified um so this will address those
without
encumbering the system quite frankly our
office the office of the child advocate
encounters children regularly who could
benefit from the proposed needs
assessment in senate bill 94
and certainly from avoiding the system
involvement that they're in once we
we've met them children themselves
know that their parents need mental
health or substance use treatment in
addition to whatever their needs are
to your question madam chair about law
enforcement objecting to this bill
one police officer recently told us in
one of our affinity groups that
children are better off in the juvenile
justice system because their parents are
so dysfunctional
and unable to help them and and we know
this is an ineffective way to do
juvenile justice or child welfare
but it does reflect the reality that the
police encounter
on the street every day so they actually
may not even have a
vision for what a child looks like when
he or she
and his family are being supported the
way that they need to be
so hopefully we're going to be able to
transform a lot of that thinking
as this plays out it's far more likely
that a child will get back on track
if their needs are identified and met
and the family is supported in a way
that they can grow strong and gain
capacity to manage their family's
challenges
so yesterday i had a conversation with a
boy at the sununu youth services center
who told me that what young people need
if they're old enough is help getting a
job
and then he said if they're not old
enough it may be that their parents need
help getting a job
and it's wonderful when you propose a
need for a policy that a child actually
confirms for you
and never underestimate how smart these
kids are
um so i suspect were he to undergo that
assessment
that need in their family for employment
for family economic stability would
probably be identified and we could
address it and he wouldn't be in the
high end of the system where he is today
so for those reasons i encourage you to
support senate bill 94
and i thank you very much for taking my
testimony if you have questions i
welcome them
thank you representative long
thank you madam chair uh miss o'neill
um are you aware of any police training
with reference
to this
with reference to this bill well yeah
well specifically the actions of this
bill
yeah so i think that director ribson did
explain that we
that that's been part of the work that
we're doing
we've been having these gatherings um
and we have some com
i mean we have we've reached out to so
far we've spoken to probably
five or six hundred people on this issue
many stakeholders many people who are
interested
um and if you attended the affinity
groups you know that we actually went
into
um you know little uh meetings with
folks like a focus group and had
their opportunity to share information
with us and now we have
three four more um convenings coming up
where we'll go a little bit more deeply
into this
and continue those conversations that's
a really is an important piece of it
to to be able to engage especially law
enforcement
prosecutors the people who are
encountering these kids every day to be
able to understand what the changes will
be
that's great thank you thank you
okay are there any further questions for
miss o'neil
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you madam chair and i did
submit written testimony you should have
it i sent my email thank you
thank you so much okay that's
um is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
i see mr head has raised his hand again
but you've
already testified i'll let you if you
wanted to add
input to a question but i really don't
want to get into debate back and forth
once testimony has been given
so mr head go ahead thank you madam
chair
and i appreciate that i was um just
wanted to loop back on
representative long's question regarding
the numbers if they were i did
manage to find it and pull it up and
really what it looks like
is the the groupings are really to
distribute them so
they're not top heavy so that we have
sort of an even distribution
of cases among the circuits as it's
being rolled out
rather than just doing all light ones or
all very heavy districts
they're really balancing the numbers
throughout the various districts so that
they can be rolled out evenly
excellent thank you so much for that
thank you and thank you for letting me
come back on
okay all right so um
that's it for um senate bill 94
i will tell you that 14 people signed in
in support
27 in opposition and i will close the
public hearing
on sb 94. i'm going to give the clerk a
few minutes and give
everyone a few minutes to get their
cameras on so we can go ahead and go
into executive session for sp94
so we'll just go for two minutes
just let me know when you're ready um
madame clarke
who do you want um okay
[Music]
yes is the manchester police
on the opposition do you know i did not
see them the only the one i noticed
was the new hampshire chiefs of police
the new hampshire association chiefs of
police
what is your chief's name again a lot of
them came in with just names
representing
themselves not even an organism
alden berg berg
yeah i don't i don't see him on here
okay nope
that's fine i i just needed to know if i
needed to talk to him or not
i don't see it i know i see one of mine
on there so i'm gonna have to get a call
i do not yes
who is calling me representative i'm
gonna take my hand down
um could you before we begin the
executive session or
as we begin the executive session could
you please read the names
the 14 in support and the 27 in
opposition
from the blue sheet or the sign in sheet
whatever we're calling it now
read their names yes please because we
can't see it
okay
you should have it in your email oh
there's an email with it
okay let me check that christina dyer
sent it out this morning
thank you i'll go take a look
if not perhaps christina could send it
out again
uh no i see it okay good
madam chair i'm ready when you are
actually it doesn't it doesn't say who
signed it just says that people signed
the only thing i have in this email is
who's signed up to
speak not the people who signed and
support or opposition
i don't have the list that goes below
where they signed up
nope christina
yes so there should be um the numbers at
the top of the page
right you can see that you want the full
list of the people
yeah i just want to hear who who signed
in and support and who signed in
opposition
before we begin i will send that to you
right now
thank you you're welcome thank you all
right watch my email
could it be sent to the entire committee
i don't know if that
that was what i was hoping she was going
to do thank you
yes absolutely
go madam chair yes yeah
i don't i mean as far as you know as far
as i'm concerned
um i i already know where i am with this
bill
yeah and i i'm positive on it
um you know i needed to know who so that
afterwards i could call them i certainly
understand
the uncertainty of opposition from law
enforcement
however with training or whatever i i
don't think it's going to be
an issue so i don't know if the
committee needs that
list prior to executing
uh or i mean i just want to see whose
names are on that so i'm going to give
them a call after we exact
uh to right right because
i i think that it's again at the fear of
the unknown maybe and the change
which is something you know we have to
get used to because clearly what
was being done before really isn't
working in the best interest of the kids
so
you know we have to be able to spread
our wings
and and try new things
so i'm going to ask um representative
litchfield
representative yokela can you turn your
cameras on
if you're going to vote for an exec
session
okay all right so i'm going to go ahead
and open the executive session
on senate bill 94 cody representative
belanger
he doesn't have to be in the room you're
right
but i will andrew do you have an option
yes madam chair
make promotion uh sb 94 will be otp
seconds seconded by um representative
would you like to speak to your motion
representative belanger
uh as a reformed youth i think this bill
does an excellent job
in moving away from a one-size-fits-all
approach
which is kind of where we are currently
that's why i support this bill
it's important not to pass motion
is there any further discussion
all right well seeing none i will have
the clerk called the roll
thank you madam chair
vice chair representative de simone
yes
madam chair representative rice yes
representative no
representative yes
representative belanger yes
representative litchfield
yes
representative yeah
focus energy yes
representative ocs
representative grossman yes
representative yes
representative russia yes
representative petraeum yes
representative of yes
[Music]
[Applause]
no you object to it being put on
constraint
no okay so without objection
sb94 will be placed on the consent
calendar
okay folks so i'm closing the exact
session on sb 94
and that seems to be the end of our
business
so i want to thank all of you so much i
really truly appreciate all of you
the time the effort the work the great
questions everything
um and we can look forward to our
next term when we start meeting again
we'll see you all the next health
session
so everyone please have a great day
thanks so much
christina can you put the feed for me
i'm sorry could you repeat that did you
cut the feet
absolutely yeah